en fin de en fin de vie financière dans
15 jours c'est pas grave ça veut dire le
21 septembre pour l'automne voilà pour
l'automne
paiement non c'est vrai non franchement
qu'est-ce qui va se passer bah vous
savez que c'est l'argent c'est on tombe
pas un œuf donc quand il y a plus il y
en a plus et alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe dans 15 jours
donc un jour j'ai des échéances que je
ne pourrai pas honorer parce que j'avais
un ami qui m'avait proposé une caution
qui ne m'a pas non pas fait pas proposé
tu m'as demandé ça tu crois vraiment que
moi je vais te proposer
alors
l'Irak sur un mec qui claque des
millions alors qu'il y a tellement de
gens qui essayent de sortir de la mouise
comment avoir la moindre sympathie pour
ce genre de personnage faut vraiment
reculer devant rien pour annoncer devant
des milieux téléspectateurs cogner
autant et faire appel à la charité alors
il a pas fait appel à la charité
tout ce que j'ai su reçu comme message
sur Twitter et autres alors je m'en bats
les steaks par exemple je rencontre fou
j'ai toujours été extrêmement
transparent la question c'est est-ce que
je dois l'expliquer ou pas à TPMP on a
une règle et que on dit des choses et on
les dit avec le cœur et on les dit
franchement effectivement il y avait des
gens qui avaient commencé il y a
quelques années à balancer dans la
presse et cetera que j'étais
effectivement dans dans la grosse merde
et j'étais dans la grosse merde c'est
l'histoire là on monte il y a 10 ans
la question se pose tout le monde se
pose
je vais réexpliquer une bonne fois pour
toute ce qui s'est passé il y a 10 ans
j'ai fait ce qu'on a ce qu'on appelle
une faillite voilà j'étais j'avais
effectivement eu des placements qui
étaient très mauvais j'ai enchaîné un
licenciement à TF1 un accident de moto
effectivement les choses se sont mal en
gougoupiller effectivement j'avais plus
rien et on m'a tout repris c'est pas
grave ça date d'il y a 10 ans grâce à
Cyril et c'est pas du tout un suçage en
règle je vais je le redis il y a 7 ans
j'ai commencé à travailler et j'ai
commencé à me réorganiser pour faire
face à pas mal de dettes mais on peut
pas faire face à toutes les dettes en
même temps c'est très simple quand vous
devez autant d'argent que j'en devais on
fait des choix voilà mais les gens se
disent comment tu as pu devoir autant
d'argent c'est ça c'est pas tout
raconter mais bon il y a un plan un
mauvais placement de près de 3 millions
qui qui était liquidé à 300000 il y a
moi ma partie à moi j'ai vécu et je
regrette rien parce que je j'ai eu la
chance de vivre comme 0,00 % des gens en
France à part Cyril personne a vécu
comme moi donc
je suis très heureux et effectivement
j'ai eu une très belle vie si demain je
mourrais j'aurai une vie extraordinaire
j'ai connu des moments incroyables j'ai
eu des beaux moments de carrière j'ai
connu des succès incroyable j'ai vu ah
j'ai eu un peu un peu d'argent moins
d'argent j'étais j'étais ruiné à 20 ans
j'étais millionnaire à 35
et je serai millionnaire dans 5 ans
rassurez-vous tout ira bien c'est une
question de temps avec de la patience et
du saindoux un éléphant enfile un poux
donc
après je ne me plains absolument pas et
effectivement et effectivement c'est
indécent avec tout ce que connaissait
français qu'on puisse penser que je
viens de raconter les choses qui sont
effectivement indécentes avec des sommes
que j'ai même manipulées géré et gagner
que j'ai gagné avec mon travail et mon
talent point barre et j'en ai fait ce
que j'en ai bien voulu donc après les
leçons de morale je m'entends pas le
coquillage qui me pèle à tarte ça c'est
très clair je ne regrette rien tarte
après effectivement j'avais été un peu
plus prudent ce serait un peu mieux
aujourd'hui mais vu ce que j'ai eu comme
comme mauvaise et comme arnaque il y a
d'ailleurs des procès qui sont en cours
il y aura un jugement donc je me ferai
et je vous raconterai tout ça qu'on
s'arrêtait jugé je peux pas en parler
avant mais il y a des gens qui ont été
qui m'ont escroquer voilà donc c'est
tout après le reste que j'ai préféré
l'hélicoptère que j'ai fait que je fasse
du 4x4 où j'ai fait du 4K que j'ai eu
des bateaux et pas des bateaux des
grandes maisons des petites maisons des
jacuzzi pas jacuzzi que j'ai mis mes
initiales dans mon hammam oui je l'ai
fait ça me faisait marrer j'ai mis mon
nom baissé mais c'est des conneries
voilà après il y en a qui c'est dans
votre salle de bain voilà bon et après
très bien oui j'ai pris des démons j'en
prends plus mais tout ça n'est pas grave
après ne vous fatiguez pas sur les
réseaux à m'insulter ça ne me fait
absolument rien voilà donc ça ça ne me
dit allez-y fais déverser votre fiel je
mange je m'en bats les steaks en
revanche c'est vrai que comme ici alors
si parenthèse ici on rigole beaucoup on
dit beaucoup de conneries avec Cyril
c'est un jeu évidemment donc il y a des
choses qui sont dites alors c'est
parfois même le point reprends des des
infos très bien tant mieux mais ici on
est là pour rigoler on se marie Cyril le
Chari je suis parfaitement complice avec
lui tout va bien il y a pas
d'humiliation il y a pas de victimes il
y a pas tout ça donc rassurez-vous tout
va bien c'est vrai que les mecs
donc pour en finir avec tout ça voilà la
vie est ainsi faite je vais très bien et
quand je déconnais à moitié sur la fin
de financière c'est vrai qu'il y a des
échéances qui arrivent là parce que
comme je fais face à toutes mes lettres
depuis maintenant 5 ans il le sait Cyril
même qui concerne Benji pour être tout à
fait puisqu'on est transparent à tous
les mois je rembourse une partie que
j'avais que j'ai pas eu avec Benji donc
à vous Cyril non mais voilà on dit les
choses
on dit des choses ou pas on les dit
beaucoup donc maintenant effectivement
quand effectivement tu es dans un dans
un dans un ajustement financier que ça
ajoute à ça des choses qui sont normales
qui sont les impôts parce que je gagne
bien ma vie très bien ma vie forcément A
+ B + C+D ça peut coincer mais c'est
tout hein vous inquiétez pas je j'aurais
toujours un toit j'aurais toujours à
manger je l'espère au pire j'irai voir
Cyril ouais c'est vrai on verra la
maison à la maison voilà donc il y a pas
de problème mais voilà je pense que
c'est bien et je pense que bien parfois
dans la vie de dire les choses de pas
avoir honte effectivement il y a des je
veux dire il y en a il y en a on dit des
trucs ici pour rigoler
contre nous on n'a pas compris qu'on
rigolait voilà c'est insupportable rien
ça c'est ils sont scoop ils sont tombés
pareil on est sûr qu'on sera toujours
donc moi je dis bah non on est
tranquille voilà donc
mettez de la viande je vais la bouffer
il y a pas de problème donc continuer ça
me dérangera pas mais non mais vraiment
donc végétarien
ça me fait juste un peu parfois ça
m'embête un peu parce qu'effectivement
il y a 43000 à l'aide Google par rapport
à mes enfants à qui on dit alors ton
père a pu un rond et qu'il emmène hein
bon et c'est cool hein comme on dit ça
veut dire bienvenu
[Rires]
les gens voilà des des gens des des
personnes
non mais non mais d'autres oui lui
d'autre
ça fait trois fois que tu me mets dans
la salle non mais en plus en plus là
c'est c'est non mais il y a plein de
gens qui disent voilà il a été
extrêmement riche voilà je te le dise ok
non mais je répète
comment il a pu faire et c'est vrai que
quand tu dévisses mais non mais c'est
marqué moi je vous dis est-ce que tu
peux il y a 10 ans je veux dire quand
vous avez quand vous avez une personne
soit dans votre porte et qu'elle reparle
avec vos voitures dans un très beau caca
d'ailleurs à l'époque que j'avais me
chercher et qu'après on vous prend la
maison et qu'on vous prend les meubles
qu'on vous prend les montres que vous
vendez les bah ça fait partie de la vie
vous savez quoi c'est pas normal
et après comme dirait l'autre quand on
est quand on est rabaissé humilié vous
savez dans la Torah quand on est humilié
et ben en fait ça ça vous répare donc
moi c'est ça ça me fait du bien
certaines des varails exactement
ça veut dire si je suis il pleut dans la
rue prends un parapluie c'est ça
donc moi tout va bien et après je trouve
ça dingue effectivement donc ce qu'on
puisse dire dans l'émission parce que on
fait preuve de transparence et
d'honnêteté mais parfois évidemment il y
a quand même 50% de darka donc les mecs
dans qui font 80 %
des deux secondes est-ce que vous
écrivez
beaucoup d'argent ou moins on divise la
même façon et c'est pareil ça fait rire
vraiment connard c'est moi connard en
fait
[Applaudissements]
si tu veux Siri je vais le dire quand tu
les vis je te dévisses
est-ce que tu peux nous réexpliquer ça
sérieusement mon préféré
non mais voilà après si tu dévisses en
fait je veux dire franchement moi j'ai
connu
mais j'ai connu vraiment le truc où tu
vas à la carte bleue il y a plus un
billet qui sort quoi tu as pas de 10
balles en poche alors non mais quand un
mois avant tu avais reçu bien sûr je
sais mais quand tu as des cartes comme
le black et que tu en as plus une seule
qui marche ça te ça te surprend non ben
non vous avez la carte blanche niveau
en fait
extrêmement extrêmement confortable
extrêmement confortable mais bon
oui et donc voilà donc voilà donc
effectivement j'aurais dû être un peu
plus un peu plus
on avait dit il faut pas y toucher Nico
vous savez bien il y a quelque chose
donc
[Rires]
il y a des sujets
jusqu'à un certain d'accord t'inquiète
pas je le ferai plus
bon alors d'abord vous êtes un excellent
ami vous êtes formidable et votre
plaidoyer très sincère mais moi je suis
chaud ok je suis choqué parce que les
gens qui gagnent le SMIC qui gagnent
c'est incompréhensible pour eux que vous
n'ayez pas mis de côté que vous ne
changiez pas de mode de vie que vous
partiez encore en vacances que parfois
vous preniez l'hélicoptère pour les gens
c'est incompréhensible donc vous vous
êtes en fin de vie financière mais les
gens chacun du mois et en plus quoi
nourrir leurs enfants donc moi moi
franchement il s'exprime avec sincérité
mais je trouve qu'il y a une certaine
indécence démo Clément il en peut plus
de toi mais c'est une démagogie pas
possible en fait en France on ne peut
pas parler d'argent avant en France il
faudrait qu'il y ait que des pauvres il
faudrait penser cosmicar évidemment qui
sont smicard évidemment qu'ils ont des
fin de vie des fins de mois difficiles
mais on a aussi le droit d'être riche on
a aussi le droit de bien gagner sa vie
et c'est pas parce qu'on gagne bien sa
vie qu'on doit fermer sa gueule et qu'on
doit penser uniquement aux gens en face
qui évidemment sont dans la pénibilité
tout le temps évidemment
mais est-ce que ça veut dire que dans
ces cas-là ceux qui gagnent ça bien bien
leur vie doivent fermer leur gueule dans
ces cas-là
[Musique]
de Gilles qui parce que les gens gagnent
pas bien leur vie ceux qui gagnent bien
leur vie voilà c'est tout le temps les
[ __ ] de riches pauvre en l'occurrence
non mais c'est compliqué d'exhiber comme
ça son ex-fort
pardon mais on a assisté à une Master
Class de Benjamin Castaldi je le trouve
juste incroyable il est plein de
panaches il est sincère il est
transparent il joue le jeu
arrête avec ça aussi comme personne ici
sur ce plateau il donne tout il mouche
alors on peut pas enfin je veux dire on
n'est pas égaux face à une gestion
d'argent on peut être riche on n'est pas
diplômé en comment on va gérer son
argent on peut faire des erreurs et des
sportifs de haut niveau ici quand on a
reçu un des footballeurs qui ont gagné
beaucoup d'argent tu étais pas à dire oh
là là Ludovic jolie c'est scandaleux
comment vous avez mal géré votre argent
voilà il y a des mauvaises rencontres il
y a des on se fait arnaquer mais je
trouve que voilà il est il est il est
juste exemplaire dans cette manière d'en
parler voilà je trouve
la vie de Sofia moi je trouve important
ben moi je trouve qu'en France c'est
trop honteux de pas avoir assez d'argent
être honteux d'en avoir trop et moi je
trouve ça super respectable que tu
assumes autant ta situation financière
devant tout le monde surtout que dans la
société d'aujourd'hui pour un oui pour
annonce fait tailler sur les réseaux
sociaux moi-même qui suis exposé sur les
réseaux sociaux je n'installe même pas
en rêve l'application Twitter
c'est vrai que Daniel c'est un peu
l'équivalent
[Rires]
indépendamment de celui dont on ne peut
pas parler non moi j'adore la façon dont
on parle Benjamin mais parler comme ça
et parler de l'hélicoptère et que tu
avais gagné au casino mais on a envie de
dire mais mais le côté ne le moi je
pense que c'est sa générosité qui l'a
perdu et c'est sa générosité dans tous
les sens c'est à dire que même même
encore winnella il nous offre du
champagne pour son anniversaire il peut
pas s'en empêcher et c'est ça génial on
en parlait donc voilà on peut pas le but
comme ça que ça choque et moi-même qui
est voilà je suis choqué par certains
propos mais je vais raconter que j'ai
jamais raconté ah vous savez comment
comment ça se fait
dire ah mais est-ce que tu as Ken avec
Nikos
[Applaudissements]
il y a quand même des limites quoi il y
a des choses dont on peut pas parler
elle est vraiment géniale
on en parlera après mais pas voilà en
plateau on est en direct c'est des
sujets
et surtout pas parler de ça et là enfin
c'est pas bien ce que tu fais
que
Monsieur
[Musique]
caillou
incroyable ça résume assez bien ma vie
quand j'étais sur TF1 avec d'ailleurs
avec avec Valérie
sur célébrité que M6 m'a appelé pour
nouvelle souvenirs non pour faire
évidemment à l'époque c'était pas cette
période là que Nico s'est arrivé
et en fait en fait à l'époque savoir que
passer de TF1 et 10 c'était un non-sens
parce qu'effectivement il y avait eu
l'exemple de Delperier qui avait fait le
transfert pour 300 millions qui avait
été catastrophique et moi j'étais
vraiment dans le doute mais est-ce que
c'est vraiment une bonne idée d'aller
faire ses missions etc et j'étais avec
Jérôme béglée qui m'attend et le patron
de du JDD et il dit tu sais ce qu'on va
faire on va aller au casino et on va
aller mettre de l'argent sur le 6 si on
met sur le 6 et que le système tombe ici
ton contrat ce que je vous raconte est
véridique on est parti donc on est parti
à Enghien-les-Bains j'ai pris des sous
j'ai tout mis sur le 6 et le 6 est tombé
et j'ai signé par le premier le premier
numéro de vous j'ai un témoin bégulé
pour avoir raconté je suis sur la tête
sur la tête de la Torah
la Bible et du
coranes
elle raconte absolument Benjamin et ça a
été absolument incroyable c'est pas un
gestionnaire Benjamin c'est pas
quelqu'un de rationnel Benjamin il va à
l'instant Benjamin si on lui dit qu'il
qu'on l'aime et ben il vous aime en
retour enfin il sait pas il calcule
jamais et moi ce que j'aime chez
Benjamin c'est que évidemment que ceux
qui nous regardent disent mais mais quel
imbécile mais pourquoi il a fait pas pas
fait si
on imagine qu'il aurait fallu faire si
faire ça sauf que c'est intrinsèquement
qui il est et que par ailleurs il ne se
plaint pas il répond aux questions qu'on
lui pose en toute transparence il
pourrait voter en touche et dire écoutez
j'ai pas envie d'en parler c'est
douloureux ou enfin c'est un dessin là
il répond il joue le jeu on va pas lui
reprocher de jouer transparence on n'en
peux plus des gens qui font la morale
comme Gilles Verdez dit qui es-tu pour
juger qui es-tu pour juger des finances
de Benjamin Castaldi tu es pas son
conseiller Crédit Mutuel donc arrête
je pense que Benjamin sans qu'on a pas
de vécu ce qu'il a vécu une on ne peut
pas comprendre ce qui s'est passé il a
gagné énormément d'argent il a eu une
notoriété recula toujours mais immense
c'est une énorme star il a présenté le
meuf c'est un phénomène de société il a
peut-être eu des mauvaises
fréquentations à ce moment-là c'est
quelqu'un d'entier et franchement il a
les couilles d'assumer toutes ses
finances contrairement à tous les
animateurs faux cul qui disait moi je
gagne 2000 euros 3000 euros lui il
balance les chiffres et il pose ses
couilles sur la table pardon de le dire
donc voilà franchement si vous pouvez
éviter
à 100% et ça le rend très touchant
d'être aussi transparent sur ses
finances
Delphine moi je trouve ça très bien ton
message parce qu'en fait tu fais de la
prévention quelque part on peut se dire
même si on a eu des millions et des
millions on peut dévisser exactement
voilà
quand on débute on dévisse il y a
d'autres personnes qui gagnent moins
mais si on vit un peu au-dessus de ses
moyens même par moment ça peut nous
rattraper donc je trouve que c'est un
beau message de prévention
ça va arrêter non est-ce qu'on peut y
penser soi-même je pense que Nico s'y
pense
[Rires]
je vais faire un Bertrand d'équerre ça
je vais quitter
de ma gueule
il y a eu non
parce que pendant la pub ils m'ont dit
que je peux pas dire ça
ils m'ont dit que Daniel elle avait
oh c'est chaud
ça à Saint-Orens apparemment avec
désolé j'ai pas les finances pour y
aller ça t'auras et que sans toi en
Grèce quoi à côté de chez Mathieu et
apparemment tu as avorté de Nikos
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je fais que répéter ce qu'on m'a dit
ça
je veux pas me faire virer mais
c'était un duo maléfique
et il y en a un qui est habillé très
flashy
business
[Applaudissements]
je peux vous dire un truc mais vraiment
vraiment c'est le seul homme qui t'a
prise m'a offert des fleurs je n'en dis
pas plus
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai donc je le remercie
rien que pour ça parce que après
l'émission et voilà c'est la grande
classe personne ne m'a jamais offert des
fleurs
un petit boutique hôtel à Santorin et il
y aurait du violon
bien sûr on raconte des conneries à Nino
pendant la pub voilà et
tout est possible aujourd'hui